dylan uh are you there i'm there hey man
what's up
yo yo all right let's jump into charts
then we'll talk about sentiment kind of
market structure stuff uh this first
chart you've got you got the bitcoin
nasdaq futures 28 day rolling
correlation
what is uh what is this showing us here
yeah so uh this is technically it's like
672 hour but uh four week rolling
correlation uh at 93 percent uh 0.93 so
basically tick for tick even though the
scales are a little bit different
wherever the nasdaq goes bitcoin goes
essentially um you know bitcoin
for bitcoiners is treated as a risk-off
asset it's a monetary safe haven
but increasingly over 2020 2021 it's
been adopted by macro allocators
and it's treated to them as a risk-on
asset and so um you know i think there's
there's somewhat of a bigger picture
being missed but you know that's
opportunity for everybody that's that's
happily stacking away so you know if
someone wants to sell bitcoin because of
auto correlations and you know just a
volatility model right you know the vic
spikes look at every time the vix
locally spikes i believe i put the chart
in uh but every time the vix has spiked
uh if we look in like say in a big way
march of 2020 but even like local kind
of vix uh correlations right here is the
march right here is the march 2020 you
can see that big drop in uh um price
yeah and that's that's the big one and
then we have an even kind of a more
zoomed up version uh you can see kind of
the last two months i've basically been
every time there's been a a spike in the
vix volatility index for the s p risk
off in equities bitcoin's kind of hit
somewhat of a local bottom um or or you
know sold off in a way um and so there's
obviously its own variables in the
bitcoin market there's derivatives
uh there's its own traders that don't
even probably look good equities but for
the last two months really the the tail
of the tape has been bitcoin
is uh being treated as a as a risk-on
asset and when things go risk off
bitcoin takes a hit and so um you know
that's kind of that's where we are in
the monetization phase uh it's treated
as a check on central bank
irresponsibility and if central banks
become marginally more responsible which
the markets have kind of priced in as a
as a probability then bitcoin's gonna
take a hit and that's and that's fine
and so when you think about correlation
between bitcoin and some of these other
uh nasdaq etc type uh assets
is bitcoin the leading indicator or the
stocks the leading indicator like do you
have a sense for which one is leading
the other or they're just moving in
lockstep and it doesn't actually matter
they just go together
yeah funny enough i think bitcoin has
actually become more of a pure signal in
terms of like risk on risk off uh just
it seems like it's it's more of a free
market obviously uh there's there's a
lot
more capital in these equity markets and
it's like a lot of it's kind of just
auto allocated by pensions and all this
uh where they just they just need to
establish some sort of some sort of
allocation and lock it in
um there's you know tens of trillions of
dollars of assets in these equity
markets where bitcoin isn't even
trillion dollar asset and so funny
enough when we saw the vix spiking
uh i believe two weeks back uh hit like
38 and it was really bloody monday and
then the
following tuesday after uh where
equities closed in the green both times
with the nasdaq down like four and a
half percent bitcoin bought them first
both of those days and we could see like
in the spot order books that there's
some huge buyers on coinbase just
happily stacking away in in huge volumes
and so what that kind of tells me is you
know the correlation is obviously there
but bitcoin is being increasingly viewed
as you know this more pure signal of the
kind of a check on the financial system
uh and and how unsustainable it is and
so it's almost like a leading indicator
we saw that in march of 2020 as well
bitcoin obviously is much more volatile
50 in the day but it bottomed
two weeks before equities and it was up
40 by the time that equities ultimately
bottomed in that march uh 2020 moment so
that's kind of how i think of it going
forward is is the volatility spike done
are we going to see a liquidity crunch
in 2022 maybe and if anyone tells you
they know they they're just lying
but ultimately i think coming out of it
how the response is after some sort of
liquidity crunch uh that's where bitcoin
really takes off
got it and then when we start to think
about some of the other instruments
around bitcoin let's look at the
perpetual's funding rate uh versus kind
of like an annualized basis what are you
seeing there
yeah so uh we talked about this a lot uh
but here we actually took like an
annualized figure of it so in bitcoin
there's a couple different type of
futures instruments there's that
perpetual futures which is just a
futures contract that never expires it
just rolls over and then you have like
the quarterlys which is more in line
with like traditional commodity future
markets right like uh every three months
there's a quarterly futures expiry and
so we can take like the spread between
the current spot market and and what
that futures price is and we can have a
basis spread and so if we annualize that
we kind of get like almost a market
neutral or risk-free uh rate in the
bitcoin markets and so
uh during april that was hitting like
these really really high uh high figures
like 40 50 plus uh in those perpetual
swap markets basically
it's kind of this this basis between the
the spot price uh and that
the funding essentially keeps
incentivizes uh allocators to to remain
tethered to that spot price and so if
the derivative is trading far above the
spot market funding will be really
really positive so this is a 168 hour
moving average of that perp's funding
and it's annualized but basically when
what you see in in february there is
that traders were paying 100
annualized uh to long bitcoin
right so obviously that's not
sustainable uh it kind of shows you that
these capital markets are the wild wild
west uh but for some investors it was a
really big opportunity you got paid you
know outrageous rates to just short
bitcoin and you could not even like
short it with your entire net worth you
just if you won x short bitcoin you're
holding a synthetic dollar so you could
you could harvest 50 100 annualized
yields for a week on end for just
sitting in dollar positions and so you
know we can kind of see these boom and
bust cycles and bitcoin with on chain
indicators but we can also see it uh and
kind of the sentiment cycles in the
bitcoin derivatives market and right now
uh we're basically completely muted uh
we're not we're not like severely
negative but over the last week purpose
funding has been on average negative so
what we really kind of see is it's not
derivative driven at all and actually
all kind of long speculation is has
basically been driven out over the last
two months
got it and so when you see us down uh
kind of flat do you think we have to go
super negative uh before we get any sort
of upward price movement or how do you
think about funding uh being positive or
negative in price
yeah so i mean usually in bull markets
uh
it's always different this time it's
different everybody longs their longs
you see the basis futures funding it
explodes upwards as everyone's just
trying to margin margin-long bitcoin
margin along crypto and during bear
markets you saw the same thing at the
bottom of the 2018 cycle
everybody thinks bitcoin's dead it's all
over you know they're longing the
absolute or they're shorting the
absolute bottom and you see that like
the perps market drives far below the
spot market and so it's almost like uh
their derivatives are trying to like
push that volleyball underwater that's
how i describe it they're pushing a
beach ball underwater um we're naturally
that spot market is
that you know gravity or physics is
gonna take over and uh we can't really
go any lower and so we're not we're not
that total capitulation phase yet where
derivatives are are you know driving
driving us into the dirt but you know
most of that that speculative air has
been kind of sucked out of the room and
so uh right now bitcoin seems to be
pretty fairly priced from a derivative
side of things
and i think you know depending on equity
correlations uh we can we can see some
higher prices here but that long kind of
speculative activity that we see a lot
of times in bitcoin cycles it's really
not there today which is actually a
really good sign for bulls
got it and then if we look at the
short-term holders and the long-term
holders they obviously
act very differently given they're
different in time horizon what are you
seeing there in kind of that ratio
between the short-term holders and
long-term holders
yeah so
talk about this chart a lot this is the
cost basis ratio so we can see like the
average cost basis of short-term holders
average cost basis of long-term holders
uh and really there's a pretty big
historical significance to what these
two cost basis are doing relative to
each other so when you think about
bitcoin bull markets why does bitcoin
price go up well bitcoin price it's an
absolutely scarce asset the bitcoin the
bitcoin price goes up when the marginal
seller is exhausted it's basically that
simple and obviously there's more to it
but when that marginal seller is
exhausted it takes just a small amount
of capital for bitcoin to really really
run
so when we can see when the marginal
seller is exhausted when one you know
you have the short term holders have
really kind of capitulated or um or and
or rather you see long-term holders have
like a significant sum of supply like a
relative large amount of that
circulating supply um so this cost basis
ratio when it's trending down means that
short-term holders the cost basis is
rising relative to those long-term
holders so why is that happening well
long-term holders have cornered the
market uh and any new capital that comes
in any new money short term holder on
chain bitcoin that we can see moving
around transferring hands um that has to
increase because they have to compete
for that free float they have to compete
for those bitcoins that are on the
market for sale and so we see uh during
bull markets that that short term holder
cost basis really explodes relative to
the long-term older cost basis and
during bear markets during downtrends we
see that uh it's kind of the opposite
and there's some capitulation in play or
that long-term holder cost basis is
increasing because there's a pretty
massive accumulation not happening so
we're in somewhat of an uptrend for this
metric which means we're not that
accumulation phase but this is kind of
that that spring loading up for that
bull market we're seeing that
accumulation phase happen again we're
seeing some of that uh short-term holder
money capitulating a loss
and this is really what kind of you know
drives future bull markets when that
when that marginal macro seller that
we're talking about of course is trading
equities or you know
just looking at the vix
when when those flipped to marginal
buyers or you know marginal buyers in a
big way that spring's really going to be
primed and bitcoins i think that's when
bitcoin really runs yeah it's absolutely
fascinating to kind of watch how this uh
part of the cycle has been different
than the past cycles and i do think that
a lot of it is because there's a
different type of
investor a different type of holder
that's in the market they treat the
asset differently and they act
differently talk to me about those
long-term holders and their ability to
hold so that if they do sell it's in
profit versus at a loss which kind of
goes hand in hand with what you're just
talking about but what are you seeing
there
yeah so this is just a relative
long-term holder supply as a percent of
circulating we take out exchange
balances because there's some noise in
that metric it's been trending down the
past couple months or the past couple
years that that exchange balance but
right now we see essentially if you look
at like the bitcoin price chart and we
look at this long-term holder uh kind of
supply uh as a relative percent of
circulating we see that we're kind of in
like this really big like accumulation
or like bear market territory almost uh
before bitcoin goes parabolic and so
what this tells me uh and kind of when
we're looking at the past couple months
is that the demand side has always
looked great i mean we saw a little bit
of distribution a little bit of profit
taking but for the most part the demand
side of the spring has been loaded since
since september since the fall but we
haven't seen the supply side of things
so on chain analytics like you got a lot
of it's got a lot of hate recently a lot
of people have been kind of saying oh
it's nonsense what about the supply
squeeze the reality is the supply has
stayed squeezed i mean it's looked it's
looking extremely good since november
but uh that catalyst for for funds
moving in for for increasing amount of
capital to allocate just hasn't been
there so it's still it's still uh kind
of in that supply squeeze type zone uh
there's still a pretty small relative
free float for new capital to come in
and bid up uh but we have to see that
that tide turn and so we're still primed
and we're priming day by day more and
more
but you know we got to see that marginal
flip of selling to buying from uh the
macro funds the long short hedge funds
got it and then when you look at the
daily transfer volume and kind of the
efficiency of settlement
i recently was explaining to somebody
that the average bitcoin fee is under
two dollars and the average fee for some
of these other blockchains is uh
significantly higher it's actually
significantly higher than bitcoin ever
was um so talking about these kind of
transfer volumes on a daily basis and
that's settlement efficiency
yeah so basically it took the the
average fee
and divided it by the change adjusted
average daily volume so change adjusted
is just a way to kind of signal out some
of that noise in the transfer volume
it's a little bit lower that's a little
technical we don't need to delve into
that but basically we can see uh on a
like how much bitcoin transfers on on
daily basis per every dollar in fees
right so uh for someone like elizabeth
warren that says okay bitcoin waste
energy well here we have a global
monetary network that's apolitical
non-sovereign there's no ceo there's no
board
there's no off switch that's
transferring on average over the last
two weeks 35 billion dollars a day
globally permissionlessly uh and for
every 85 000 dollars of settlement
volume final settlement like not like
swiping your debit card which isn't
final settlement that's just a company
marking up their own kind of database
but like final settlement of value
across the world 85 000 of it for every
one dollar in cost so
the
the percentage cost of that settlement
is 0.0001
[Music]
or whatever whatever it is um and if
you're looking at like say you know
ethereum and this is why i think the
comparisons are just outright dumb uh to
be frank because they're they're so much
different um ethereum in terms of
settlement volume as as a you know per
one dollar in fees it's at 171 dollars
right because because bitcoin is a
settlement network it's it's purpose
built to store value and settle value uh
in the most efficient manner possible
ethereum isn't it's a smart contract
network you can do all sorts of things
with nfts or d5 or all sorts of things
with smart contracts but it's not a
purpose-built monetary settlement
network like bitcoin is um and so when
we think about just how efficient
bitcoin is at doing this one thing it's
purpose-built to do
nothing else competes and that's uh kind
of why we're you know hammering the
table constantly being bullish because
we see a huge problem in the world and
that money's broken uh and you know it
presents a few hundred trillion dollars
worth of opportunity that we think
bitcoin is pretty prime to take um and
so
all these sort of like you know all
these sort of blockchain solana ethereum
whatever else kind of altcoin you think
is is novel that's fine but they're
competing for something else entirely uh
in terms of being you know a
permissionless decentralized truly
decentralized settlement network nothing
else competes with bitcoin uh and it's
it's not really close
got it and then when you start to think
about um kind of where we go from here
it seems like you're really paying
attention to funding you're paying
attention a lot to kind of the
consolidation of
of holders are we just watching the
transfer from short-term weekends to
kind of strong long-term uh focused
individuals and therefore uh it's a kind
of a repeat of what we saw maybe in the
summer of 2021 that eventually led to
kind of a replay of the bull market
yeah i think we're somewhere uh i think
we're a little bit kind of like 2020
almost where i mean we haven't really
seen a huge macro capitulation like to
the extent that we saw in march of 2020
but we saw a vic spike we saw in nasdaq
20 off the highs
bitcoin 50 off the highs
all the kind of
short money or like the the unconvicted
holders are are out of the market if you
you know if you were a little if you're
unconvicted then you already sold uh and
really it's just kind of those toddlers
of last resort those stackers of last
resort uh that understand bitcoin's the
best money the world's ever seen and
they're accumulating and so uh we saw
bitcoin range at nine thousand dollars
for months in 2020 while while every
other asset was moving but under the
surface that supply got tighter and
tighter and tighter and so i think
that's what's going on today i mean we
can see that's what's going on today uh
and in reality like you know it's it's a
pretty good time to buy opportunity like
to buy bitcoin relative to the news
events that's happening the geopolitical
game theory that we talked about just a
couple weeks ago pomp it's picked up
even since then um and so it's really
exciting times and i think bitcoin is is
extremely undervalued uh relative to
just what's happened in the last year i
mean if we're thinking about bitcoin
being as cheap as it was a year ago a
lot has happened since then and so uh
you know i believe it's pretty
undervalued here and again i'm a buyer
got it john you got any questions yeah
dylan i'm curious what the data is
showing about the support levels i've
heard everything from when we were going
down 50 000
was a support 40 000 was a support 30
thousands of support where does that sit
now
yeah uh i mean from a kind of a
technical level which i i think has has
a lot of merit um there's a lot of
limit orders there's a lot of buy
interest at 32 000 at that 30 000 level
um it was tested just briefly uh during
the height of that kind of macro
sell-off and so uh i expect if we get
there again strong support there uh 28
000 kind of that summer the the the
march or i'm sorry the summer open or
the summer close as well as like kind of
the 2021 open uh that's really a pretty
strong support level and i think uh a
lot of kind of like risk models and uh
derivatives are are set to kind of right
like right at that threshold so if we go
below there it could get a little ugly i
don't think we will but again non-zero
probability but that's what i'm kind of
seeing for support in terms of
resistance on the way up kind of those
key levels the big round numbers are are
probably going to be some resistance for
the for the time being
but i think you know once once that kind
of like again that macro flips uh it
really it's gonna be like most of the
resistance is probably like butter on
the way up as that marginal seller is
just it's just not there uh you know
most of most of the weekends have
already kind of capitulated at this
point that makes sense
dylan before uh before we let you go
what when you think about uh kind of
sentiment in general oh i think a lot
about like uh price comes down people
obviously get less excited there's not
as much kind of fomo hype you know
frothiness whatever uh but we still see
you know michael saylor buying 660
bitcoin we see yesterday jack dorsey uh
clearly articulating what's going on in
the bitcoin world and kind of how he
sees the asset why it's so important
like how much of the dying down of the
froth and hype is healthy uh and you
know isn't necessarily reflective of
some sort of uh slowdown in progress of
bitcoin versus is that something that
you worry about where you see sentiment
you know kind of tailing off if you will
no i mean i think this is just nothing
but a thing i mean it's not for anyone
that's that's new here it's like and i'm
not i'm not some grizzled vet like i've
only been in the market for a few years
but uh you know relatives when i first
started allocating uh bitcoin
significantly higher and for anyone in
2021 or 2022 that just started buying in
this is underwater i think
you should embrace it because the
reality is uh bitcoin just with with
absolute scarcity and with uh the kind
of the individual game theory at play uh
everybody's trying to acquire a bigger
slice of this of this supply and so uh
you know bitcoin's underlying number go
up technology
uh ultimately will always kind of win
out and so you'll kind of wish you
stacked at lower prices and so no i mean
i think nothing's nothing's changed
obviously the price uh marginal seller
marginal buyer uh price has gone down
derivatives are are not overly extended
you know we'd be higher if if there was
some uh kind of speculative activity in
the derivative market but it's totally
healthy i mean we've seen this over and
over again bitcoin's not going to go
away you have bill miller coming out
saying you know he has 50 of his net
worth and bitcoin a lot of billionaires
are opening their eyes when he says that
so
uh yeah just nothing but a thing i mean
we're going to see nation states adopt
bitcoin over the next 10 years mine
bitcoin it's gonna be legal tender we
have states proposing as legal tender
tahini's restaurants just went out and
talked to the canadian house committee
and said we should buy 10 billion
dollars of bitcoin like obviously i'm
not that you know it probably won't
happen tomorrow but you know these
things are are accelerating and and the
trend is is pretty clear if you just
zoom out more than a couple months i
love the tahinis guys they just continue
to push the taste awesome just literally
just killing it absolutely amazing um
all right let's do uh we got a quick
follower uh follower update on you where
where you at
uh
i think 120 something like that
120. right i think when we first started
doing this you were what like 60 70 80
something like that
i'm not sure to be honest yeah he just
just went away to the moon that's what
dylan's follower count 500k by the end
of the year
all right where can we send people to
folly what's your twitter handle and
where uh where should we sign up for the
newsletter
yeah so uh the charts i showed today uh
just a brief sneak peek of our monthly
report we're dropping um it's gonna
we're you know dropping some facts about
blockchain analytics uh bitcoin
derivatives and kind of the macro
outlook so uh just took about like a
quarter of the charts that were laying
out uh in that report so subscribe to
the deep dive uh if you're interested in
that i think it's gonna be a banger uh
it's in my bio if you're interested so
that's kind of what we're covering and
you know if you enjoy make sure to check
it out
awesome john
any last comment
dylan you're streaming on twitch now
oh
uh yeah i mean it's kind of an impromptu
thing i just uh you know twitter spaces
is fun but uh we don't get the visual
right like i like doing the visual here
with you guys and so uh i've hopped on
with will a couple times and we just
just look at trading view and all that
and just
shoot the [ __ ] so uh you know pop if you
guys are interested in coming on i
wouldn't do that sometimes i think i'd
pay like i don't know maybe maybe five
dollars a month just to see dylan and
will communicate with each other dude
did you see the rsi
you too in a conversation uh like via
text when no when you know no one's
watching i can only imagine how much fun
you guys are having so yeah we have a
good time i i appreciate you coming on
we will do this again next tuesday
uh and cue up the great work man people
learn a lot so it's super super valuable
appreciate you guys have a nice week see
you later buddy